i
[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en parís un programa de radio
france internacional en colaboración con
la televisión france24 en español el
mundo vive una situación de urgencia la
tierra los mares se agotan de manera
acelerada por causa de la polución y la
sobreexplotación de sus recursos
diversos estudios demuestran que
asistimos a un cambio acelerado del
clima de consecuencias incalculables y
al mismo tiempo se pide que gobiernos y
políticos actúen de manera acelerada no
obstante está claro que la respuesta de
estos deja mucho que desear sus
respuestas hasta el día de hoy son
claramente insuficientes para hablar de
una de las propuestas alternativas a
este cambio climático saludamos aquí en
nuestro estudio a christopher córdoba
coordinador de la iniciativa global
climate organización invitada a parís
con motivo del cual tu cuarto foro por
la edición sobre la paz que se realiza
actualmente en la capital francesa una
organización que ha sido seleccionada
entre otros 80 proyectos por las
propuestas que ofrece precisamente al
cambio climático christopher bienvenido
a esta escala en parís
climent
a la inteligencia artificial por el
clima explique dos concretamente que
representa esto cómo funciona esa
organización el objetivo principal es
ayudar a acelerar la conversación y
ayudar a ordenar también esta
conversación sobre cómo las nuevas
tecnologías sobre todo inteligencia
artificial pero muchas más también de
fronteras pueden ayudar a conservar la
re conservación de la naturaleza a la
conservación de la biodiversidad y
también a la lucha contra el cambio
climático es decir acelerar la
conversación para que podamos tener una
conversación mucho más equilibrada mucho
más amplia a nivel global con muchos más
actores mucho más inclusiva pero también
mucho más efectiva y entonces podamos
tener casos de uso de muchísimos países
de muchas industrias diferentes y con
esta perspectiva mucho más amplia
podemos ser mucho más eficientes en la
protección de la naturaleza diciendo
ustedes que se trata de aprovechar el
poder de la inteligencia artificial para
ayudar a la resiliencia climática cómo
funcionan más allá de la conversación de
las discusiones que ustedes tienen es
muy interesante porque en realidad
tenemos que empezar siempre de la
conversación a partir de esa especie de
diálogo comienza con un diálogo
justamente con eventos que reúnen a
expertos de muchísimos países pero
también de muchos temas diferentes y
entonces esto permite identificar casos
de uso identificar tecnologías
identificar avances de fronteras
identificar dónde están los puntos
nuevos de quiebre donde se está
empujando esta frontera hacia afuera
entonces a partir de eso es que después
podemos comenzar a incentivar el uso de
estos casos precisamente donde ha habido
nuevos aprendizajes donde ha habido
nuevas exploraciones y entonces poder
ayudar a que se disemine y tener un
impacto mucho mayor es usted el director
global de aid for climate que proyectos
impulsan completamente por ejemplo en
américa latina en américa latina se ha
conducido en la reserva de dzilam en
yucatán si se ha conducido un estudio
muy interesante con apoyo también de del
gobierno de quebec en canadá y con el
gobierno local en yucatán y con
distintas instancias y muchos grupos
también académicos
sobre los manglares en un ecosistema
absolutamente fascinante un ecosistema
muy rico donde hay desde selva baja
hasta manglares y hasta pastos marinos
es un ecosistema muy muy peculiar y esta
exploración de cuáles son las
tecnologías cuáles son los usos ideales
cuáles son las combinaciones y también
cuáles son los actores que tendrían que
estar más adelante en la implementación
de todo esto ha sido parte de la
exploración que nos consciente es en el
caso de méxico tienen otros proyectos o
otros asociados en américa latina que
estén desarrollando proyectos nuevos en
este terreno o solo es el caso y no el
américa latina más bien a nivel
internacional hemos estado en un proceso
muy muy profundo de exploración para
encontrar estos aliados en muchísimos
países sobre todo lo que nos hemos ha
dedicado a buscar en los últimos meses
además de speakers para los eventos que
tenemos es justo de esos casos de
desarrollo tecnológico muy puntual que
están ahora ocurriendo por todo el mundo
en donde alguien está utilizando nuevas
tecnologías por ejemplo para sonido
otros para imagen otros análisis de
datos otros para poder entender mejor y
combinar como plataformas de tecnologías
que pueden combinar y hacer que los
sistemas tecnológicos se hablen entre sí
todo esto es parte de la exploración y
nos da una perspectiva mucho más amplia
de hacia dónde tenemos que empujar un
poquito tratar de de mover la
conversación y la cooperación
internacional al final de cuentas
christopher usted mencionó al igual que
el derecho a un medio ambiente saludable
y sostenible debe convertirse en nuestra
máxima prioridad no obstante no todos
los gobiernos lo entienden así
efectivamente hay muchísimos muchísimos
retrasos en materia en esta materia a
nivel internacional pero también
partimos de que no estamos arrancando de
un suelo común todavía hay una brecha
tecnológica muy grande no solo entre
países sino también entre regiones y
esto hace muy complejo por lo tal
necesitamos una mesa común necesitamos
iniciar la conversación a partir de que
estemos hablando el mismo idioma que
significa inteligencia artificial
aplicada para esto creemos que es la
primera pregunta que necesitamos tratar
de responder y tratar de diseminar estas
respuestas también para poder partir de
una base común precisamente la
inteligencia artificial sin duda alguna
es una tecnología de lo más avanzado en
el mundo de vanguardia pero cómo se
aplica este juego precisamente de
algoritmos que incluyen aparte de esto a
un caso concreto usted me hacía
referencia a la reserva que está en
quintana roo en mexico como están
aplicando esto concretamente como ayuda
a renovar oa preservar una reserva
natural como el caso que usted evoca
un ejemplo muy concreto sonido
cuando hay tala de árboles se emite un
sonido específico una sierra eléctrica
emite un sonido especial de fuerte por
cierto el exacto y que es distinto al
sonido de un camión que está pasando o
es distinto a el sonido de un ave o al
sonido de un humano que está avanzando
es distinto a todos los demás sonidos lo
que ocurre aquí es los algoritmos se
pueden entrenar para identificar un
sonido muy específico incluso a grandes
distancias y a partir de eso poder
georeferenciar exactamente dónde está
ocurriendo entonces eso es un caso muy
concreto pero se puede aplicar con color
para identificar un tipo de pez
específico en un coral después
identificar con patrones de migración de
aves por ejemplo en una laguna se puede
realmente entrenar a los algoritmos a
que nos ayuden a identificar cosas muy
específicas y que eso ayude a determinar
la salud o los riesgos de un ecosistema
y por lo tanto podamos actuar de una
manera mucho más rápida imagino que una
vez que tienen esa información de
carácter global hay una especie de
filtros a partir también de los diálogos
que ustedes mantienen decía es una
iniciativa global entonces supongo que
tienen comunicación de eeuu con países
europeos con organizaciones de otros
países cómo se hace dijéramos cómo se
van tomando las decisiones para aplicar
tal o cual decisión en un momento dado
en un caso concreto cada organización
cada institución cada país al final de
cuentas va a utilizar las herramientas
que encuentran viables los sistemas de
información que encuentra viables no
obstante digamos nuestro nuestra labor
en este momento ya está donde dejamos
esta contribución es tratar de hacer que
sean más visibles las herramientas y los
casos de uso más avanzados es decir el
estado de arte la frontera lo que está
pasando lo que están haciendo los
organismos más avanzados en cada uno de
estos aspectos hacerlo más visible
ponerlo más disponible ponerlo en la
mesa para que todos los grupos puedan
tomar mejor de manera más informada las
decisiones en cuanto a qué tecnologías o
incluso no todo es tecnología porque no
vamos a resolver todo esto solo con
tecnología incluso con quien colaboró
quien ya lo está haciendo qué proceso de
cooperación internacional es el adecuado
o con quién necesito trabajar con qué
institución en qué país para hacer esto
que necesito hacer en mi propio país los
recursos que ustedes utilizan vienen de
donadores me imagino una cuestión que
ustedes están manejando es el principio
de la adopción por pagando por ejemplo
para el caso de méxico que usted
desbocaba es decir se le pide a la gente
adoptar un pedazo de selva a un pedazo
de reserva cómo funciona esto cuál es la
ventaja cuáles son las desventajas de
este tipo de iniciativa primero que nada
es un tema de apropiación si sientes que
algo es tuyo si comienzas a tener un
tema de identificación con un espacio
una reserva natural un tipo de especie
un ecosistema concreto incluso un metro
cuadrado llevado al terreno tan concreto
de un metro cuadrado de esta
biodiversidad de este ecosistema se
genera una identidad se genera un
vínculo es lo más importante porque eso
ayuda también a que hay una mucha mayor
receptividad a qué es lo que está siendo
un riesgo para ese ecosistema que es lo
que está pasando ahí y por qué me
interesa pues me interesa porque ahora
ya tengo un vínculo entonces tiene que
partir por ahí y obviamente tiene que
derivar en mecanismos mucho más
complejos de financiamiento en donde
juegan grandes entidades internacionales
en donde precisamente tenemos que partir
de estos suelos comunes de esta de esta
base común de conversación y de entender
cuáles son las estrategias de
financiamiento que están disponibles a
nivel internacional
pero siempre lo mismo siempre tenemos
que llegar a que esta identificación nos
ayude a tener una mejor comprensión de
lo que está pasando en la naturaleza
lamentablemente la biodiversidad que
sostiene nuestra vida e incluso los
procesos complejos por los cuales la
degradación de los ecosistemas nos
llevan a estos grandes riesgos
climáticos siguen siendo invisibles para
nosotros sabemos exactamente qué está
pasando aquí en parís en cualquier
momento tenemos muchas fuentes de datos
pero no sabemos qué está pasando a
ciencia cierta en las reservas naturales
en los grandes ecosistemas alrededor del
mundo es esta brecha una de las más
importantes que tenemos que hacer y una
de las maneras más efectivas es generar
un vínculo es generar una identificación
con lo que está pasando en la naturaleza
pero hay una cosa que me interpela es yo
por ejemplo quiero adoptar un pedazo de
una reserva natural puede ser en la
amazonía puede ser en eeuu en rusia
normalmente la reserva son reservas
generalmente de carácter federal como
interactúa una asociación como la de
ustedes con un poder federal y este
principio de apropiarse porque
finalmente cierre reserva federal no se
la pueden apropiar como funciones es un
equipo muy complicado me parece a mí sí
claro no todas las reservas naturales
son públicas también reservas privadas y
también reservas comunales es es
bastante más complejo y cada país tiene
incluso una manera distinta de nombrar a
las reservas algunos son parques
nacionales reservas de la biósfera es
decir aún el espectro de lo que llamamos
una reserva natural es bastante complejo
desde un punto de vista institucional
ahora sin entrar en detalles muy
profundos pero como funcionaría el tema
de adoptar un espacio simplemente
estamos hablando de poder financiar la
el despliegue
d sea un estudio o en su momento más
adelante cuando todo se de esa fase esté
desde plenamente con completa más
adelante se pueda financiar también el
despliegue tecnológico necesario para la
protección garantizada por un periodo de
tiempo determinado con unas ciertas
variables determinadas con un cierto
número de actores y ciertas
características de los actores
interactuando para lograr esta
protección sostenida a lo largo de un
tiempo nos quedan veinte segundos cuál
ha sido la respuesta que han recibido
ustedes de organismos y de gobiernos a
este después de este respecto que estaba
en 20 segundos por favor ha sido una
positiva el ente excelente respuesta
sobre todo porque se ha reconocido de
manera muy profunda
la falta de datos pero también la falta
de nuevas maneras de combinar
tecnologías y ahí es donde hemos
encontrado el mayor potencial pues hay
muchas opciones para trabajar estamos
llegando ya al final de este escala en
parís
agradezco a christophe córdoba su
presencia en esta escala muchas gracias
por habernos acompañado a ustedes les
damos una nueva cita la próxima semana
aquí en otra escala en parís